[Musique]
chaque semaine de nouveaux produits
alimentaires nous sont proposés
mérite-il d'entrer dans notre panier
d'épicerie sont ils à prendre ou à
laisser aujourd'hui du macaroni au
fromage le retour d'un sandwich décadent
et on commence avec du lait de la
compagnie américaine fait relâche ce qui
a attiré notre attention demain c'est le
50 % moins de 50% plus de protéines ce
ne sont pas les seuls trois autres joie
sur le marché qui me font des promesses
similaires au niveau du sucre et des
protéines après avoir vérifié
l'étiquetage nutritionnel de un je vous
confirme que les allégations sont
véridiques donc il ya bel et bien 50 %
moins de sucre est 50% plus de protéines
que dans un les blancs dits ordinaires
en fait on a affaire à un procédé qu'on
appelle de deux trappes filtration le
lait va être passée au travers de
filtres très sophistiqué dont les
petites roues permettent de retenir des
molécules d'une taille très précises ils
vont filtrer à part les protéines le
sucre dans le cas des protéines
évidemment pour qu'on nous a légué 50%
plus de protéines ce parce qu'on les a
non seulement remis mais on en avait mis
plus dans le cas du sucre même principe
de base on filtre on retient mais on ne
leur met pas dans le produit dont qui en
ont enlevé l'équivalent de 50% et c'est
ce qui fait qu'on en a moins genton
d'issue at on précisé au quai les cadres
d'ajouter dieu à moins qu'on se retrouve
avec du lait ou chocolat du léon fred
quelque chose aromatiques comme ça mais
dans les blancs de consommation c'est
interdit donc le sucre on retrouve
habituellement dans n'importe quel est
le blanc c'est le sucre naturellement
présent dans le lait qui est à 99% du
lac taureau qui a très très peu
d'influencé sur la glycémie dont il pas
le type de sucre qu'on considère comme
étant problématiques ou dommageables
pour la santé l'argument de moins de
sucre dans les ca sert à personne à mon
humble avis c'est marketing d'abord et
avant tout le lait est un aliment qui en
soi est tellement nutritive il n'y a pas
d'intérêt à ce qu'on se préoccupe de la
quantité de sucre dans du lait à mon
avis alors faire life à prendre ou à
laisser à prendre si l'ajout de
protéines est un argument ou un attribut
qui pour nous préférence mais
définitivement pas à prendre
spécifiquement sur l'argument du sucre
c'est marketing si par contre on est
achat local fait relâche est une
compagnie qui appartient à un coca cola
et le lait qui est dans cette bouteille
loeb vient de l'ontario
maintenant un nouveau produit de la
compagnie gogo kinois macaroni au
fromage qui éveillait et bio des tirs
semblent la fois
oui
beaucoup kinois qui est une entreprise
québécoise qui existe déjà depuis
plusieurs années une offre toujours sans
gluten on remplace le blé
essentiellement par le quinoa ce qui est
très intéressant comme ingrédient de
substitution parce que c'est beaucoup
plus nourrissant que bien d'autres
substituts qui sont souvent utilisés
dans les produits sans gluten comme le
riz ou le tapioca qui contient
malheureusement pas grand chose et si on
le compare au légendaire kraft dinner je
voudrais que deux éléments particuliers
pour lesquels il ya vraiment un avantage
sur ce produit de quand on compare au
créneau les fibres qui sont beaucoup
plus élevés et le sucre qui est beaucoup
plus bas cela dit pour le reste des
valeurs nutritives matières grasses
sodium protéines c'est très similaire au
niveau des protéines y en a un petit peu
plus du côté du crabe des neiges
notamment parce qu'on est une sauce à
base de fromage le produit est
évidemment un peu plus cher parce qu'il
est bio parce qu'il est sans gluten
parce qu'il est végétalien n'ont plus de
travail et des ingrédients de lens qui
sont plus dispendieux ceux de vos bijoux
c'est deux fois plus cher
en fait pour moi c'est un produit qui
est intéressant est ce que c'est
tellement plus santé que l'autre de
façon très significative la réponse est
non donc ça reste pour moi un bon
dépanneur d'occasion ou le genre de
petit report à edu qui est pas mal sûr
de plaire monde est-ce que c'est à
manger tous les jours pas vraiment parce
que ça reste très salée
chaque trois ans depuis 2010 pfk remet
sur le marché pour un temps limité sont
extravagants sandwich coup double alors
regardez je me dis que l'objectif
premier c'est vraiment de faire parler
de pfk c'est réussi nous allons en
parler bravo pour la créativité on a
remplacé le pain par du poulet frit et
howie en bas mais ça donne quelque chose
d'assez à la fois spectaculaire et
étrangers ça fait penser à ce restaurant
de las vegas qui vous fait des double
triple quadruple pontage
4 boulettes de viande bécane et toutes
sortes de choses en termes de matières
grasses et de sodium on est dans quel on
les aborde personnes vont être surpris
quand on parle de remplacer le pain par
du poulet prix bas tout ce qui est gros
total gras saturés cholestérol et sodium
on est dans les hautes sphères on parle
d'autres 40 g de matière grasse sodium
on est à 1530 mg ce qui veut dire qu'à
manger ce jeu remplit plus que 100 % de
ce que mon corps a besoin dans la
journée au complet en terme de protéines
la chose est sûre c'est que ces
nourrissons on parle de 46 grammes de
protéines
si on compare avec un big mac par
exemple on n'est pas loin mais pas si
loin que ça au niveau des calories au
niveau du groupe même au niveau du
sodium mais reste que si on compare avec
un big bang est ce que le big mac est
tellement plus santé la réponse est non
alors le sandwich coup double de pfk à
prendre ou à laisser ça passe par un
choix santé que c'est un choix plaisir
d'avoir et akon
et oui à prendre si votre curiosité ne
peut s'en passer j'aurais envie de
recommander de proposer de partager
parce que mandy les en deux il ya des
bonnes choses que vous soyez
dans ma bouche c'est tellement grosse
tellement sale et que je sais pas trop
ce que je mange finalement moi j'aime
beaucoup le poulet frit mais c'est trop
trop cheap ce trop gros con tout
[Musique]